And the
volcanic group
is what is leading
Putin's war right now, right now
making the only known progress
on the battlefield for Putin.
That means the man running Russia's
most powerful
private army
is making a name for himself.
Here is Evgeni
Prigozhin publicly
declaring that
his men are the ones who captured a town
just outside the key city of Buccleuch
This meal is the image
that we can safely say
that the settlement of Clean Shipka,
which is one of the most important
suburbs of Bermuda,
has been completely
taken under the control of Wagner
PMC units exclusively by volunteer
PMC units.
At least Rivka has been liberated
a bit It's incredible.
Exclusively by Wagner.
Wagner is not the Russian defense.
It's not the Russian military.
It's a separate group and emphasizing
this word exclusively that it was
he and not they.
And he's taking it
even further than that.
He has been openly criticizing
Russia's official military leaders
with them, with them.
I have had the deepest combat experience
for eight years
now, in many ways
vastly superior
to the experience
of those
who have been
in the service
of the Defense Ministry for decades.
It is me.
It's incredible. Right.
And what is most incredible about
all of that
is if Vladimir Putin appears
to be completely fine with it.
And maybe that's why Russian politicians
are also happy to back
Prigozhin
and his sort of Prigozhin versus
the Russian military institution
Just look at this picture
from prominent Russian
lawmaker Sergei Mironov.
So you see him there.
He is holding a sledgehammer.
It is a Bognor sledgehammer.
This is a very provocative picture
because Wagner boasts
about having the sledge hammer
as their official symbol.
So why? Why?
Because a sledge hammer
was used to murder
a Wagner group fighter
who tried to flee the battlefield
last year.
And now look at him.
They're brandishing it.
And while Russia's
official military suffers
from a lack of pretty much
everything as basic as ammunition
when it comes to fighting,
Prigozhin has appears
to be getting more weapons.
Sort of.
They're completely owned supply chain.
Take a look at these pictures.
I'm going to show you this these,
we understand,
to be images
of what appear to be Russian rail cars
traveling to North Korea,
picking up
infantry rockets and missiles, weapons
that according to the United States,
then went straight to Prigozhin
and Wagner fighters in Ukraine.
And the concern tonight
is that North Korea might deliver
even more lethal military equipment
to Prigozhin specifically.
Ben Wedeman is OUTFRONT
live in Kramatorsk, Ukraine.
And Ben,
you're there on the ground in back today
where some of the fiercest fighting
is taking place.
You hear
Prigozhin claiming victory
in a suburb of Bok move.
What did you see in here?
Well, Erin, we've been going
to Bermuda
fairly regularly for the past two
and a half weeks or so.
And what we're seeing is
the fighting
is just getting more and more intense
and that the Russian noose around
Bermuda is tightening
in the trenches outside Bermuda.
A mortar crew is at work.
We're still
hoping to repel Russian forces
on the verge of encircling
the city, Kristie.
Drone footage
shows
the impact of their rounds
on enemy positions.
The refrain among these troops,
we know more
oh, speaks about dance, dance, dance.
Yes, of course, that is more powerful
for our time machine.
So a field.
But now is 21st century.
We need not only to dance,
we need to aviation
around Bermuda slowly and steadily.
The Russians are gaining ground
for Thursday.
Yevgeny Prigozhin,
head of the Wagner
group, claimed his troops
and only his troops
took the village of Clichy after
just south of the city.
Was not in the dugout.
This officer,
nicknamed Calypso,
explains Wagner's tactics o Saloon,
who took the codename from the Heights
they attack at night.
The first wave is less trained,
but we have to use
lots of ammunition against them, he says.
The next wave of troops has night
vision is better
trained and better equipped with the
plan.
Tactics, seemingly
from a different day
and age, inflicting
mounting casualties on Ukrainian forces
This soldier was critically wounded
when his armored personnel carrier
was struck by Russian fire
Much of Barmouth is now a ghost town.
The sound of shelling, the danger,
the constant
inside this tunnel, inside Barmouth
taking cover
because there's incoming rounds
just nearby,
keeping the few civilians left.
Resigned to their fate.
So people died from strikes
everywhere in Kiev
and DeNiro, says Valentino.
If that's your destiny, death
will meet you anywhere.
Not just the
spotlight.
On a hill above the city.
The Soviet era, the T-72
tank fires into the distance.
Its sound and fury perhaps
not enough to turn the tide
and that tank,
that T-72 tank is more than 50 years old.
We've seen other artillery for instance,
that dates back to 1950.
Older than me.
And this is why the Ukrainians
are so insistent
that they need modern weapons to fight
the Russians.
And we heard the deputy defense minister
of Ukraine say today that Ukraine
is disappointed with the German hesitance
to provide them
with these leopard two tanks.
And they say
they really need these weapons
and they need them now.
I mean, amazing
how many of those
ancient by any
and any measure here in modern warfare
weapons.
They want those cluster
precision munitions. They want all of it.
Thank you so much, Ben. Wedeman.
And now retired Air Force Colonel
Cedric Leighton and Peter
Rowe, who just wrote
an extensive article about Wagner group
chief Evgeny Prigozhin.
He's director of the Hudson Institute
Center on Europe and Asia.
Colonel Leighton, let me start with you.
When you hear
Ben talking about back
where he spent so much time
and saying Russia is slowly
and steadily gaining ground,
you know,
you hear Prigozhin today
claiming that he exclusively. Right.
Took took a suburb,
a village
south of the city of Block Mute.
How significant
is the Russian performance here?
I mean, we understood, you know,
so later
that was
it was very clear
was was a marginal
to no strategic importance back.
What is different
Yeah, it sure is there.
And the key thing here is that
although the amount
is not the center of great industry
or the center of a military base,
it is astride one of the main highways
that leads into eastern Ukraine.
And so because of that
and also because of the symbolic nature
that both sides have really made of this
this town, the idea here
for the Russians is to capture it
at any price.
They don't really care
what they're capturing.
The main fact
is that they're capturing something.
And so Obama has become
this kind of a symbol
for both the Russians
and for the Ukrainians,
for the Ukrainians.
It's basically a symbol of resistance
for the Russians.
It's a symbol,
they hope,
of their victory in the future
and in the weeks to come. Right.
To have any kind of a victory.
And, of course,
within Russia,
you've got the Russian military
and you've got the Wagner group
led by Evgeny Prigozhin.
So you've got
you've got this war going on inside
Russia's military operation.
And, Peter,
you know, we heard Prigozhin
claiming that the Wagner group
is exclusively liberated,
this suburb of Bermuda.
Those are the words
he used, of course, to take full credit.
And I want to play more of what he
said in this new video
message with
the armed forces of Ukraine work
clearly and harmoniously.
We have a lot to learn from them.
But in any case,
the units of PMC Wagner
are moving forward.
Meter by meter
So they're moving for a meter by a meter.
He's claiming full credit.
But in there, something significant.
We have a lot to learn from them.
The armed forces of Ukraine work
clearly in harmoniously
these compliments.
Then what is his goal here?
Well, I think
any promotion is obviously an oligarch
and kleptocrats,
which is what in modern day
Russia passes for a businessman.
But he does not just have
pecuniary interests,
which has been long speculated
that he wants to
capture these parts of Ukraine
because of the salt mines
or the gypsum mines,
lucrative parts
of Ukraine and its vast resources.
Now, by stepping out
and in recent weeks,
also, for example, claiming credit
for the Internet Research Agency,
which he established
in Russia,
Second City Saint Petersburg,
from which
Western intelligence claims
that the Russians
have been sowing discord
in Western societies.
On top of that,
he has also bragged
about Wagner deployments
in Africa, where,
for example, in Mali,
they have attempted
to push out the French
or in Syria where they openly challenged
the United States in combat.
Now, increasingly,
by pushing out
is becoming much more
than just a kleptocratic oligarch,
if you will.
He is now becoming
a political military figure
and clearly is aiming
at the power structure in Moscow.
And I'd say he's doing that
in two respects.
One, through these open comments,
which he's
taking in a second, through slickly
produced videos that the Concord Group,
which is his public relations
outfit, has been releasing of him
visiting the front lines,
cutting a strong figure,
leading his troops,
so to speak, towards combat.
All of that,
I think, suggests a transformation
and a real move towards power in Moscow.
Well, it's
significant when you talk
about the business interests.
He's got his own PR group.
All of this is
this is just a person
who has some mercenaries
running around that he gets from prisons.
It is important for people
to understand the
context and the depth here.